es una realidad el presidente demócrata
joe biden convirtió en ley el plan de
rescate para paliar la crisis económica
dejada por la pandemia 19 billones de
dólares en ayudas y estímulos
creo que esta ley es histórica trata de
reconstruir la columna vertebral de este
país y darle a su gente gente
trabajadora clase media gente que ha
construido el país una oportunidad de
luchar esta es su esencia
datos diarios
era una de las puntas de lanza de la
campaña de bailén durante las elecciones
una promesa cumplida menos de dos meses
después de su llegada a la casa blanca
supone una victoria para el presidente
demócrata y un ejemplo de lo que puede
hacer su gobierno con mayoría en la
cámara de representantes y en el senado
aunque el proyecto no logró atraer ni un
solo voto republicano en ambas cámaras
un reflejo de la profunda división que
todavía vive el país
la ley incluye pagos directos de 1400
dólares a los estadounidenses que
ingresen menos de 75 mil dólares anuales
una suma mayor a la de los planes
anteriores firmados por trump también
dará ayudas semanales de 300 dólares a
las personas sin empleo hasta el fin del
verano y otorgará ayudas millonarias a
gobiernos locales además de prever
partidas para reabrir las escuelas
impulsar el plan de vacunación y
aumentar las pruebas de kobe 19 según la
misma casa blanca en counter royals de
sueca las primeras ayudas comenzarán a
llegar este mismo fin de semana